- So Kelly, you know we all shop online,
but there's some sites that
you know and you use a lot
and they usually already
have your credit card stored
and I use those.
But every now and then I buy things
from sites that I might
not be as familiar with.
And it's a little bit
scary 'cause as we all know
we don't want random people running around
with our credit card information or more.
How do you think about that?
What safeguards or what
should we be thinking
in the back of our minds
when we're shopping?
- Yeah, I agree.
It's challenging because you know,
ideally you'd start
with somewhere you trust
but that isn't always an option.
I think that, first off,
think about something like
HPS that will tell you
not that they're necessarily
a safe shopping site,
but at least that any
information you share
is going to them.
I'm basically saying that the site,
like traffic between you and the site,
is encrypted so that you
know that the site is the
only people getting it.
Another thing to think about is, you know
do you have to share your
credit card information?
So a lot of banks now are doing what we
call virtual credit card numbers.
So those are basically
a throwaway one time number
that they'll give you
where if it ever gets
lost or charges against it
that you don't want
it's not your normal credit card number,
so you can kind of get rid of it
and the damage is
limited to that fake one.
Virtual one.
So browsers like Chrome and also Android
have built in features to
actually take advantage of this
and make it easy for you to
input your virtual number
instead of your regular
credit card number.
- This is helpful.
I thought I was actually pretty savvy.
I didn't know about these
virtual credit card numbers.
I have to figure out
how get some of these.
Super helpful.
Thanks so much Kelly.
Sure.